c'est aussi peut-être un temps pour dire
qu'est ce que je veux vraiment faire ma
vie parce qu'on fait là on est face à la
mort au quotidien quoi je crève pas
demain qu'est ce que je fais à près de
moi je me dis ça je craque pas demain
qu'est ce que je vais après brun et qui
vraiment du sens pour vous tous domaines
dans la drôme à la rencontre d'anciens
urbain comme marine qui n'était pas
épanouis dans leur boulot en ville et
qui ont décidé de changer de vie j'ai
fait un rêve
aux changes et le monde ces néo ruraux
croît ont une vie plus lente mais aussi
aura notre rapport au travail plus
manuels plus concret où chacun apprend à
faire par soi même souvent une montagne
de ces gros août il est si grande aux
gens une fois qu'ils allaient bonne
explication bas ça serait quoi ces coûts
depuis les années 70 la drôme c'est
devenu le département laboratoire pour
toutes celles et ceux qui remettent en
cause la société de consommation
marina 29 ans et elle fait partie de
cette nouvelle génération de
décroissance
ça rentre des pollens mais de toutes les
couleurs quoi vraiment la java d'umaru
orange pétards là je suis en train de
nettoyer en fait lui plus de 50 % de
mortalité des ruches
il avait 21 ans la dernière là il m'en
reste 10 et comment tu vis à la crise
qui a en ce moment en france il va
plutôt bien
plutôt bien dans le sens où je crois
j'espère que il y avait à voir un exode
urbain et une prise de conscience qui
fait que les gens vont avoir envie de se
connecter à ce qui est vivant quoi parce
qu'en fait le virus là et pour le moment
on croit qu'il est même que de la mort
mais moi je me dis qu'il va amener de la
vie il ya sept ans j'étais en fac de
sociologie j'étais bien dans ma tête et
puis un jour j'ai eu un coup de foudre
pour la bei et je me suis dit en fait
c'est ça qui est j'ai envie de faire
puis je suis parti en stop
le complètement changé de vie à cette
époque là je suis parti dans les
cévennes puis je suis arrivé dans la
drôme le confinement
ma première réaction c'était la
jubilation c'est un peu bizarre de dire
ça mais je pense ça fait depuis que j'ai
changé de vie que j'ai des moments avec
des gros doutes et puis là c'est comme
si j'avais une sorte de validation de
pourquoi j'ai souhaité une vie plus
autonome
plus respirante plus lente
[Musique]
ouais il est prendre plein coeur d'un
domaine
non c'est pas pour moi après son passage
je vais finir coûte dans l'épicerie là
pendant deux heures en bénévoles ce
qu'on a mis en place des mesures
d'hygiène et du coup on a besoin de
quelqu'un qui accueille les gens à
l'entrée qui leur explique les mesures
pierre l'intérieur c'est une personne
qui sert tout le monde pour pas que les
gens touchés les objets en fait on se
lavent bien les mains en arrivant mais
notre masse et après on sait région
[Musique]
alors quatre pommes capote mandarine
orange quand l'épicerie du village a
fermé on était plusieurs habitants à se
dire c'est un service de proximité c'est
trop important pour la vie des villages
et du coup et qu'on peut pas faire
quelque chose sans être des
professionnels
est-ce qu'on peut pas recréer un service
de ce type mais plus résilient donc
associatif on est au maximum en bio mais
on voulait vraiment que ça soit une
épicerie avec des prix justes et
accessible pour aussi pour la population
du village est pas créer de clivage
entre des nouveaux qui mangent bio bio
et puis les anciens qui vont acheter
tous intermarché pour faire une grosse
caricature très caricatural mais l'idée
c'était que semaine l'épicerie pour tous
du coup on a fait des prix
certains produits on a ciblé on a fait à
bas prix cebu tout fait tout bon merci
bonne soirée
[Musique]
mais à la pépinière des alvéoles ici on
se réapproprie notre alimentation en
fait on apprend à faire nous même
affaire à plusieurs et ça à mon avis
c'est la clé pour la suite chaque fois
qu'on fait quelque chose on note ou
qu'est ce qu'on a fait et puis qu'est ce
qu'il reste à faire
il ya les oignons de terminer est planté
c4 lors d'une étape
robin mais marina est là moi ça fait
cinq ans que je suis parti de la ville
et que j'ai atterri
j'atterris ici j'ai fait une fac de
sport pour rentrer en école de kiné ça
n'a pas marché
et puis ça c'était en 2009 il ya une
crise financière qui est passée par là
et du coup ça a été un gros remue
méninges dans ma tête j'ai fait un peu
de la dépression d'ailleurs il y assez
rapidement j'ai découvert la
permaculture et voilà depuis ce moment
là ça a été oui c'est ça que je veux
faire en fait dans ma vie
l'assemblée l'appel qu'est ce que vous
faites
reçoit une citerne une cité en dessous
de 100 mètres cubes on s'est rendu
compte qu'on n'était pas suffisamment
résilient sur la question de l'eau c'est
un petit peu la sonnette d'alarmé qui a
été tirée la part par le début de la
crise en se disant mais si si on doit
vraiment produire de la nourriture et
bien il nous faut il va nous falloir
plus d'eau donc voilà et pourquoi cela
n'a plus de sens que puis une carrière
en ville ça c'est un peu la question que
je me pose depuis depuis sept ans il se
pique je me suis dit je ne serai pas ma
carrière en ville mais ben j'ai envie de
partir de cette planète en me disant
j'ai tout fait pour que pour qu'elle
soit parce que soit plus accueillante
mais si ça que c'est ça qui me qui
motive dans mes choix quotidien
[Musique]
ce que je peux
c'est un groupe d'habitants qui en
premier lieu vous sauvegardez donc cette
cette usine qui a donc sans ben oui cent
vingt ans et qui a voulu garder ce lieu
vivant c'est à dire passer d'une friche
industrielle à quelque chose qui puisse
servir là la vie citoyenne et avec
l'envié d'avoir un espace de travail où
il ya des professions libérales et des
artisans est aussi un lieu de partage
moi je suis paysagiste concepteur en ce
moment je travaille sur la
transformation du parking de la friche
en parc urbain écologique fait quoi je
fais
les découpes pour la frange du bas de la
toile de ma flexion une petite surtout
légère qui se replie sur elle-même en
fagots que je peux être à mal est
partout pour mes ateliers et bien ses
classes à tout droit après il ya les
fenêtres j'ai un référendum
quand c'est pas droit bon faut que
j'apprenne jamais trop faire ça pour ça
lève plein de croyances on a ouvert sur
un perçage jetables et pour ça on fait
si tu prends le temps était terrifiante
où tout est possible
[Musique]
on va faire m on va d'abord disque est
ok
eh bien c'est ce grand moment c'est
parti tiens on va découper un bout de
boue de goudron pour voir ce qui est en
dessous en fait non non non j'avoue a
pas du tout mais justement c'est
l'occase regarde si ça te comme position
ça te va comme ça si jamais les besoins
de barrie taylor
non tu veux juste eu lâché future relève
d'abord
[Musique]
comment s d'experience bah ouais je
trouve ça drôle on s'est souvent une
montagne de ces gros outils l'aide
seguros en jean et ça m'amuse de tester
à l'occaz edouard qu'en fait une fois
que tu as les bonnes explications bah
voilà ça c'est quoi donc c'est cool
parce que c'est palabres ont lieu tous
les jours d'avoir des gens qui sont pas
spécialisés un travail eh ben ça dépend
ce que c'est ta valeur haute au départ
si ta valeur c'est de faire un maximum
de tune d'être le plus productif
possible
c'est sûr que c'est pas le bon c'est pas
la bonne méthode si ta valeur c'est que
les personnels puissent tester des
choses expérimentés se dire [ __ ] je
suis capable de faire et être fière
d'elle et ressentir et ressentir une
utilité ben du coup c'est le bon moyen
bah c'est sûr que avoir des experts dans
des métiers c'est ultra important après
c'est pas une raison pour pousser les
autres personnes alors faire croire
qu'elles ont aucune compétence là c'est
tout l'enjeu en fait c'est que ça c'est
un insolent qui est stérile du coup
c'est un n'y a pas de matière organique
à c'est très très pauvres mais le but là
c'est de savoir de ce sol stérile
comment est ce que maintenant on fait
pour le rendre fertile mais là c'est bon
c'est la deuxième partie faut revenir
dans six mois quoi et là le but
justement c'est de tous les sens place
en fait ne pas envoyer ça en déchetterie
ou chez paou et de faire ramener de la
terre le but c'est certes de végétaliser
de fertiliser mais d'essayer de le faire
avec ce qu'on a déjà sur place tu vas tu
as la terre en dessous
voilà voilà un peu d'argile deux là
c'est bon
voilà presque un peu émouvant
là on est à saint quentin bon on va
boire un coup
lusine vivante au départ ça a créé un
peu détention durant oui c'est quoi
encore
ces bobos qui viennent s'installer où
ces hippies et puis en définitive
aujourd'hui quatre ans après l' usine
c'est un lieu où on vient chercher va
justement des informations sur la
transition écologique sur une autre
manière de travailler est ce que c'est
de la politique absolument c'est de la
politique non partisane où il s'est
complètement de la politique c'est
s'occuper de la cité f1 c'est participer
à la vie de la société sur le territoire
vont très loin avec ce qui vient
[Musique]
2 mm quand la boucle
du bon et comment arriver à organiser
énormément d'activités
ben les abbesses et
lundi mardi mercredi que je veux sur le
projet
[Musique]
la pépite
dix ans après
si j'ai eu le temps
et si un jour tu attends mais de
travailler qui se passe il ya un timing
il ya un agenda mai
et aussi beaucoup liberté nécessaire à
je me sens très inspiré ça n'a aucun
intérêt que je bosse en fait
donc avant je me jugeais vêtements par
rapport à sam
on propose tonné
juste qu'il nous semble que nous
un clic c'est pas nous
en fait là j'arrive pas due forme
concentrée si je
désolé mais mes cheveux
ces jeux
quand j'ai décidé de ne pas faire de
recherche ressources humaines c'était
vraiment ça le mot dire quoi c'est à
dire en fait moi j'ai envie de créer le
métier de mes rêves je prendrai le temps
qu'il faut pour arriver à faire ça qui
t'a pas gagné dessous
mais en même temps il y avait tout le
temps des voix qui venait des
positionnements des parents on aimerait
faire des trucs qui est quand même
faudrait faudrait se former il faudrait
faudrait travailler il faudrait qu'elle
était souffre il faudrait caudry
faudrait donc je vais je les ai refait
plein de fois des monges herbaut céline
géraud et pour d'autres je veux dire
quand salariés tout ça mais ça me
plaisait jamais quoi je jamais tenu bien
longtemps
et cet ancien de chez mais cette
démarche jusqu'au bout du jour n'ont pas
tous les jours bahia forcément il ya des
périodes de doute pour moi j'en ai une
femelle est ce que tu pourrais
conseiller aux gens qui hésitent quitté
en bleu on intéresse pas qui était une
vie qui nous intéresse pas mais qu'on
peur à mes conseillers quelque chose à
quelqu'un ça me met toi qu'est ce qui
t'a aidé ouais moi ce qui m'a aidé c'est
me poser la question en permanence
qu'est ce qui te fait triper mais
c'était ma boussole quoi c'est avait
atteint l'âge et de la joie à faire sa
bombe
c'est que c'est ça j'ai l'impression que
c'est un truc est partagé par peut-être
notre génération les plus jeunes
si on ne fait pas ce qui nous fait
vibrer maintenant
c'est foutu maison alors et peule a
basculé en deux roues est en train de
tout ça dababech qui va en gros ça c'est
son style s'invectivent ya peu plus à
l'est la balance à l'isen pour
et ça prend une belle sensation de créer
les choses par soi même
j'ai pas rien semble impossible du coup
l'idée d'un truc et puis après de le
guen le réaliser d'arriver au bout il ya
une satisfaction et puis c'est aussi une
fête de pour le mois c'est le fait de
pouvoir le transmettre après sa main je
pense tout de suite à ça en fait dès que
je fais un truc tu vas pour le père toi
aussi
[Musique]